this is scott and kenny has it gotten uh
has it gotten a little annoying can he
just pass the annoyment what is fast
annoying
wasn't it better when they were just
sniping at each other hey listen we were
just
first of all y'all need to stop it i
never had it man i never started i don't
haters
i would sit here you're the one who
started it contribution
goes more than a stat sheet triple
single
so you started i never said that i never
i've never had any kind of beef and you
started the beef
and i didn't do this i've seen triple
single on my instagram
too many times way too many times of
what you've seen from the phoenix suns a
team that you see a lot playing out
there on the
on the west coast and obviously devin
booker everybody knows him but this is a
team that's going down there and
and gone four and oh so far it's great
to see book playing well and phoenix
playing well but get my man
out of phoenix it's not good for him
it's not good for his career
sorry chuck but uh wow they got to get
booked out of phoenix i need my man to
go somewhere where he can play great
basketball
all the time and win because he's that
type of player are you tampering
maybe he's not a great shooter he's a
great defender
but you have to honor yourself with
kimba and that opens up things for
haywood
brown and tatum when you have a player
out there
who's who can't shoot or who's not a
great shooter teams know you can cheat
off of that guy
and that's going to make it harder on
those guys if kimball's not there
we know shots shut huh throwing shots
taking shots at me oh no no no no
come on man what are you talking about i
thought the same thing when i heard it
oh that sounds like
i thought the same thing we're talking
about marcus smart uh it's hey
you said guys sounds sound very similar
to draymond green
all right
there may be a little crack in here
great do not let kenny come between us
i'm telling you
i heard the same thing see now you're
searching kenny my eyebrow went up just
like his hero